I'm just a really big old man in the
dress but I'm celebrating the icon of my
life Nina wes is your Miss Congeniality
from the last season of drag race tell
me about this look Elsa hello it's Elsa
inspired obviously it's frozen to one of
my favorite films of all time so the
fact that I get to be here tonight to
celebrate the mayor is I wanted to like
do something big and drag but also in
alma's room I think one of the strongest
Disney heroes ever you ready for all the
children that all the celebs have
brought tonight to be like hello how
many hours went into this this this
outfit was made by my friend Jamie
Martin and it took well over a week and
a half yeah so I'm thrilled I'm thrilled
to be wearing it tonight what has it
been like for you since the season aired
like your life has changed I see you
with everyone at everything like how is
Hollywood treating you Hollywood has
been very amazing to me and they've
embraced me and I can't thank everyone
enough for wanting to have fun with some
boy from Ohio who just loves this art
and loves performance and loves film and
television and I've been the kid that
sat at home every night when the big
award season came on I popped a bullet
popcorn and sitting around the TV that
was my Super Bowl and so now that I'm
here living this dream is it's humbling
and it's amazing and I'm so honored to
be here tell me last thing I've heard
rumors that there's another season of
drag rights coming perhaps and other
all-stars if they asked you would you go
back after what happened well first of
all celebrity drag race is happening in
2020 and it's gonna be amazing
and I'm excited to be a part of that
secondly if they asked me to come back
for all-stars absolutely yeah you know
um I feel like I have some work to do
unfinished business and I'm thrilled to
be a representative of this amazing
amazing television show and RuPaul who
is who's like who is yeah everything and
so yeah they uh I would absolutely do it
in a heartbeat
[Music]